i mean you said you had a bad feeling
about some of judas moves i do have a
feeling actually it's about to collapse
i was gonna say because i mean the the
threat that is in the air is bishop
takes night and uh once that defender
goes well suddenly that knight was
holding everything together and the
queen will strap forward to line herself
up against the king and magnus
and
a bit of insight into magnus here he
likes to play one minute chess a lot
online and it's always to music he can't
play in silence he's said this in the
past so
there we go confirmed magnus listening
to the norwegian top 40 most likely
i love it and well he's feeling good
right about the game i'm just looking at
the bar after only 16 moves the bar is
really liking it for the world champion
yeah already at plus 3.5 for white and
that could well turn into plus 100 if
duda doesn't find the right defense it's
just checkmate
even if he finds the right defense now
the computer thinks that it's
terrible for blackmail